Film Courage: Pamela, with romantic comedies,
is falling in love really supposed to be funny?
Pamela Jaye Smith: [Laughs] Well falling in
love is seldom funny.
Now it’s hopefully fun.
But I think what romantic comedies and the
funny look at the situations can do for us,
it can make it easier for us to take a look
at what happens and how frightened we sometimes
get as the changes that are happening when
we start falling in love and the resistance
that comes from within and often from without,
you know from friends and family who say “What
are you doing with that person?”
And maybe society’s strictures against who
you’re falling in love with.
So to take a comedic look at some of those
situations can be helpful, because then you
can go “Okay…other people have faced this
kind of situation.
Here are some solutions.
Maybe we can work that out, too.”
Film Courage: I know in looking at your book
Romantic Comedies, you use a case studies
of MY BIG FAT GREEK WEDDING and it sounds
like we’re referring to a lot of the similar
[ideas], where the family was so strong, that
they only wanted…they were very possessive
and also too they had [the main character
- Toula Portokalos played by Nia Vardalos]
as this one type of person and kind of gave
her the impression she couldn’t have another
type of [mate].
That was the beauty of the film.
Two opposites came together.
Pamela Jaye Smith: Yes.
It’s a very good example of that.
And I also think it’s a good example of
when people say ‘Falling in Love,’ note
the word falling.
Okay?
You’re going from one position as the daughter
who always does it this way, as the member
of the family who this is the way we always
do it.
You’re falling into a different realm.
And I’ve often wondered why we don’t like
slide into love, Okay?
It’s not a horizontal movement or why we
don’t rise into love but of course if it’s
well done, you do rise up, you do have that
uplifting of your spirit.
But falling in love?
You’re falling off that level where you’ve
been.
You’re going into a different realm.
It’s a different world and so I think the
beauty of romantic comedies is that you make
it a little bit more palatable to take a look
at the things that happen to us.
Film Courage: Now why do people love romantic
comedies?
And I realize not everybody does, but we all
have a soft spot for at least one.
Pamela Jaye Smith: That’s true.
We all have a soft spot for at least one.
I will admit that when the publishers came
and we were talking about a new book, Ken
Lee said “Oh, there’s this study that
has been done and we think that maybe it would
make a good book.”
[And I said] “What was it?”
[Ken replied] “Couples who watch romantic
comedies together versus the other group of
couples who went to couples therapy.
And an amazing thing happened, the stay-together
rate was higher for those who watched comedies
together and talked about them, then it was
for those who went to couples therapy.
Now, I still think couples therapy is a good
idea.
But until you get to that point, romantic
comedies!
Now you say “Well, does everybody like romantic
comedies?”
Frankly, I didn’t that much.
When Ken Lee and I were talking about this
and he said “Well, we think you would be
a good person to write this book.”
And I said “Uh…you know I do mythology
and military stuff right and adventure?”
And he said “No…no…you’ll do a good
job with it.”
Well thanks to him and Michael Wiese (of Michael
Wiese productions) it was a group effort on
constructing how the chapters would be laid
out and how we would approach each film.
So me, a person who was not that much of a
rom-com fan, I actually became one through
the process of writing this book.
Question for the Viewers: What is your favorite
romantic comedy?